[Music]
which state deserves your hate
career site zipia oh yeah everybody's
heard of that
is this where i pitched this story so i
can't blame anybody
zipia which sounds like the name of the
weirdest dwarf
uh ranked the snobbiest states in the
country
and starting at 10 you got virginia you
got maine oregon
california rhode island which is
actually a state that's that's crazy
is it an island i guess it is and the
top five though is new hampshire
new york connecticut vermont and
massachusetts
yep if you're sensing a common theme
it's that those snobby estates
are all blue states now you know why
this is on fox
they're also they're also mostly coastal
and uh i guess that's convenient for
bragging about your summer beach home
which we all have
judge has seven i do that meanwhile i do
not
meanwhile the least snobbiest sewer
alabama
the least navies alabama arkansas
oklahoma mississippi with all those s's
and west virginia all red the states
where the fewest people pretend
to like npr of course you could be
wondering how they came up with this
list
well they weighed a bunch of factors
actually they looked at population
percentages with bachelor degrees
the percent of those in arts and
humanities and how much wine
each state consumes and also using the
phrase
oh the book was much better also
congrats to west virginia for ranking
50th where they prefer moonshine over
malbec
doesn't pair well with cheese but it
will clean
your paint brushes um i drink
a buttload of wine sure do am i a snob
no i was thinking well i was going to
say you keep hitting the judge for being
rich it's like you're not a blue-collar
guy greg
you have a summer heart
secret lair wait a second i spent most
of my life
making regular money it wasn't until
later that i was deciding so you admit
that you are rich thank you
i had to do it i i did not like the wine
correlation in the survey at all because
you know what i'm not even i don't
because
okay well because that's because you're
a thug
because she is correlating wealth with
snobbery
and that my friend oh i think it's
that's not true
okay i think wealth has nothing to do
with snobbery i also think that wine has
nothing to do with snobbery
i feel like really you disagree i drink
beer
yeah baby
is
[Laughter]
oh
it comes out worse than it goes in it
does
you're a snob i'm not i drink
yes will i have one yes i will yet
chadwick you are you a snob i'm guilty
of reverse snobbery i'm intentionally as
uncouth and uh obnoxious around people
what do you drink
stuff beer yeah what kind of beer
although i've been doing white claw
lately because the beer will make you a
little fat
that is not snob at all no it is the
alpha seltzer
but it is racist thank you for bringing
that up oh he's
talking thinking about canceling we went
almost three segments without bringing
up racism congratulations
okay obviously if it were black claw
that would be like a super villain
right yeah yeah yourself you gotta do it
don't go
there don't do it don't go there i run i
want
i want uh tyra it's about your summer
home
it's a layer it's a summer lair
it's it's basically a place where i hide
from you judge
oh gosh by the way
what do you drive she has a driver greg
i love you you're like how dare you you
see yeah you take pictures of yourself
sitting in a chair with wine
overlooking a lake going
you know what that is that was where the
robert durst case started thank you
where were you
jake all right that was my case he's
been stalking me since then
they they thought that he had the body
in there but no kidding i was a d.a who
do you think did it
sorry is this your shirt a beer do you
drink i'm gonna try it
last word to you tyrus tell me what is
snobbery define
snobbery um you got a mirror i'll point
it
right to you no man oh he had it coming
[Laughter]
i know what you care for your booze give
me self-esteem i don't care
the only thing i have issue with is new
hampshire calling people from new
hampshire snobs
it's literally the deadbeat dad state of
america before dads go to run from
paying child support
yeah i have a map
so see look you're out now i'm in but
yes and the point is though
usually snobs are the guys who don't
have money that are trying too hard
they're usually pretending you're like i
wonder how the poor i don't know you
know bro you have a roommate in an
apartment like you're not
they usually pretend it's usually snobs
are imposters it's keeping up with the
jones's mentality yeah
that's a snob i i think that's a good
definition i just want to know if the
judge would drink a tecate with me
absolutely all right that's absolutely
car bomb she's never afraid